looking very comfortable nice gets the
throw though
available he's available for both right
now there's
nice
what was that
hold on can we see that again please
because i
for the information and here's a counter
going to the wall
oh the snake is cheeky oh my goodness
things are not looking good right now
for skywalker down back to the countdown
oh my god he just did it
he needed
hey
right now
okay both players a little tentative
there didn't want to over commit did a
kia knight back sway though and if he
optimizes is this dead i don't think so
but it's gonna be very close one more
hit does it here right now the mix up no
the race traffic control
closes it out for ikea three rounds
clean two
25 seconds left
[Music]
20 seconds about even on life
dragon hammer plus frames the aop down
by two counter hits
oh now we can break on that time that
was important ten seconds left to flip
nice punish no
[Applause]
the little dance and shaolin takes the
set two games to one
tomorrow so shaolin took a bit of a
gamble oh okay the one what happened one
way to get your back away from all but
besides therefore guess the count here
not gonna be dead gonna be very close
there one more hit does it for shaolin
and okay the block that's not the punish
though
skulk you're just staying alive right
now oh my god
okay
is he gonna carry to the wall he's gonna
carry my next wall junkyard combo
just like that skywalker makes the
impossible come
[Music]
[Music]
you